first of all exercise is still the most
important intervention we have for brain
health that shouldn't be forgotten so
the exercise you're doing for your body
is also for your brain both in terms of
reducing inflammation increasing growth
factors increasing
cardiovascular fitness which in turn
increases vascular Fitness remember a
lot of dementia is exacerbated by
microvascular disease the brain is like
two percent of your body weight and 25
percent of your metabolic demand I just
reflect on that for a moment so anything
that compromises any bit of its
metabolic Fitness is disastrous and
that's why small vessel disease type 2
diabetes anything that compromises
that aspect of the brain is is is is
devastating with respect to dementia